[Music]
did you guys know that the pandemic is
affecting the mental health of the rich
more than the poor oh no not the rich
with all this money well they made [ __ ]
tons even more yeah who are we talking
about
when it's the rich because the rich rich
has [ __ ] killed it during this
billionaire billy you're doing well like
middle class rich probably because
they're saying that uh it's it's people
in a higher socioeconomic status aka
cess which is like higher education
higher income
and those two were both like they've had
greater declines in psychological
well-being over the course of the
pandemic compared to low sex
people so they were there was their life
sucked already
well if i was collecting 600 bucks every
week from unemployment and all that [ __ ]
i would have been like
yes this is better than my job that i
had before i got a friend who's doing it
who's making 900 bucks a week because
there was like an extra bonus
and he was happier than i've ever seen
him people are dying
and he's so stoked yeah i hope this
lasts
yeah yeah so they're saying that
individuals with higher education
experience a greater decrease in
depressive
symptoms and a greater decrease in life
satisfaction from
before to during the pandemic in
comparison to those with lower education
and they're saying that the reasons
might be because higher education people
they tend to
consume more of the news and that might
affect them more than low sess people
and
also uh because high sess individuals
they have a strong
expectation for a constant availability
of resources
and so when there are declines in times
of crisis like during this pandemic
they end up getting let down more than
low s
people could also be a lot of business
owners are completely [ __ ] and they're
like
the upper whatever it's true like some a
lot of businesses are never coming back
like i think i just read that like
three-fourths of some businesses are in
a certain
area are never coming back yeah i was
like on yelp or something like the
businesses that
have like temporarily closed or like
they're gonna permanently probably yeah
a
good chunk of them my buddy has a chain
of um stores
and like during that time everyone's
like all the businesses they got all
these like
freaking forgivable loans or whatever
right so he got a million dollars
in forgivable loans but the problem is
that's when they gave
everybody unemployment and all the
relief stuff right so no one wanted to
go back to work because
um you know he has minimum wage workers
so it's like
if you're getting minimum wage at a job
but if on an
unemployment you're getting 600 to a
grand a week
you're like [ __ ] that i'm gonna i'm not
gonna go back to work
he has to spend his money within a
couple of months or else
it's not forgivable but he can't even
spend it because no one's back at work
exactly so
he was just like [ __ ] and i'm like
well why would i want this loan
and i can't keep my business afloat
because no one's going to come and work
for me
and i was like dude that sucks i'm so
glad i'm not that big
so glad you got problems bro
damn that's pretty wild i know
but yeah so they're all pretty bummer
pretty bummer episode this is you know
so far
you were so excited before this oh no
i'm just thinking about all the lives
lost
oh no business is closed doors shuttered
i just think about how much fun i'm
having that's good
i would recommend people shop local oh
yeah for sure
you know shop small yeah even though i
am on amazon a lot
well no use your local amazon do what i
do local amazon yeah use your local
amazon you know they started we recently
drove by
brick and mortar um uh amazon fresh
oh fresh yeah i love friends they have a
store let's promote them at night your
buddy's business
you just walk in you pick up items walk
out it charges your account you don't
have to deal with the checkout person
that got fired that's right damn it's
all automated yeah
i love that love that the uplifting
article right
unbelievably depressing why are rich
people so
sad well they're also saying that high
sex people
they tend to have high like i said
higher life satisfaction throughout
their life anyway
and less depressive symptoms which means
that they have like a higher
dip than low-sized people yeah when i
was at vegas
and i was walking up and down the strip
and going into the casinos
everyone that was having a blast they
weren't rich people
they were people that were getting
stimulus checks and i can tell
because it felt like i was in walmart
not vegas also you saw walmart people
all over the place
hell yeah a lot like it was super
[ __ ] crazy man people were fighting
and it was like
fighting yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
is happening this is i mean there's
always fights in babies right
but it was okay it was like
why is circus circus at the wind i see
that's what it felt like and then it was
weird because i'm like
you guys are just gambling this free
money away
you should put it in the stocks or
something do you think there will be
also a gamble
yeah it's not as bad as playing slots
you think they're walking in the aria
though i'm going holy [ __ ]
this is incredible it's been here the
whole time wow
if you sit by the like the door and see
the people check in that's what you will
hear
oh my god like it's like they never
doesn't look like a castle at all
they're rolling in their own coolers
they're only used to expel
yeah and circus circus it was crazy yeah
and i was asking the uber driver too he
goes yeah man it's just
so different the whole clientele like
he's like okay because rich people
they hide out and then they're like
super cautious and they don't want to go
and like burn money and then like people
that were
that never had money to travel before
they finally get like they finally get
tons of extra money everything's cheap
they're patterns and they're just like
oh no [ __ ] vegas is open let's go
and then like they're just spending it
all like just having a good time
and i'm like well that's good for them
[ __ ] they get to travel now okay they're
not trying to live forever you know
yeah but i was just shocked because i
was like this is why the poor stay poor
man you're burning all your [ __ ]
money away
have you watched graham stefan videos
yeah he like goes in on all that [ __ ]
pretty pretty good stuff well he also
tells you to drink coffee for like 20
cents right or something
yeah he's cool yeah yeah he's cool yeah
that's what i mean
uh we dm'd him he's a nice guy wait so
what is he talking about
oh just financial like not not he's a
white guy i assume
with the name he's like a real real
estate uh financial investor like type
of dude teaches you how to like build
wealth
like that's this youtube he's a real
dick grayson looking fella
now he's really cool because he's
helping um just everyone
learn more financial education and just
real estate and just basic stuff that
they should be knowing
he says it in a way that's very
digestible yeah and he goes in on like
uh
when athletes get big checks he's like
don't just
blow it on all these i get earrings
right away right
5 000 earrings 14. those are huge
yeah big earrings yeah those aren't like
big big
um when i got money the first thing i
did was i bought a sports car then i
tried to save the rest of it but i
really wanted to buy a sports car yeah
porsche
but that was like your your kind of
dream car yeah but like i got a lot of
[ __ ] from
you know financial planners and like
people like graham
yeah and they're like don't it's a
depreciation depreciating asset you're
gonna you know
you're gonna lose money in the long run
blah blah blah did it depreciate your
heart though
no i get it in every day and i'm just
like cool see
that's good truck i have a truck too but
like i'm i get in the porsche
cool i love it and things matter to me
like that
and that's that's good though part of
what's wrong with that i kind of feel
like
everyone has to go through it though if
if it's in your personality like for me
i had to do the rockstar [ __ ] and just
burn it to experience it and go yes
i got it out of my system yeah and then
um
for other people maybe they never need
to do it so it's easier for them to be
more disciplined i guess do you do any
vesting investing
uh i just own do you own best i own
homes but that's
that's but i don't make money on them
because i live in them and my parents
live in the other one
depreciating asset yes oh no absolutely
uh you gotta kick your parents out so
you can make some money dude well you
know what
once they go i'm bringing in some
serious cash on that property but
let's hope they live another few years
but if they went tomorrow it would be
sad
but but you know my revenue would go you
see opportunity
i see opportunity where i see sadness i
see opportunity
we should talk about bitcoin if you want
to get really sad yeah
should i because i know a guy who bought
in and you know him too who bought in
when it was 19
whoa nineteen thousand yeah did he go
hard
he went hard wow
it's going to 40. yeah wow well there's
a finite amount of bitcoin so like when
it's all gone then these are gonna be
worth a million each just to give some
some like how much is it worth now oh
it's doing pretty good yeah that's not
bad it was like six
yeah it's just you gotta you gotta be in
it for the long run he just bought it at
the wrong time
wrong time but you know what wrong time
is you know
over time hopefully he'll he'll make
money if it gets a million he'll make
money
let's hope there's five years later i
think it will actually i'm one of those
guys
well look i'd love to you know learn
more about it we'll have a discussion
i think it's all timing with stocks and
investing and all this stuff a lot of it
is usually
timing so it just depends on when you
sell and when you buy
instead of it being like something where
you're like oh you failed because it's
like
if you're looking at a small window at a
time obviously you failed
like like your buddy who bought it for
19 now
he failed now but then when bitcoin hits
100 grand
right if you didn't sell did he sell i
don't know i want to bring it up because
it felt like
it was a sore spot did he become very
sad after this
no he's not uh i know him too huh is he
a comedian i think i know who he is
no oh that's even sadder because because
he ain't got no money
he's a very serious man comedians have
failures they turn into enjoyable
stories they can share with their
friends yeah if you're not a comedian
you don't have any coping mechanisms and
it actually hurts you personally yeah
but i should tell him to go like
yell at a bunch of people at a bar about
it and maybe he'll feel better he will
he really will that's his coping
mechanism yeah just yelling at people
our buddy peter and i that's where i
first bought some bitcoin was with
uh my buddy peter gilroy when we were
both at maker studios 2013.
well you bought one that long ago i
bought one that long ago so you bought
it at what i bought
a thousand each and you have how many i
can't say i'm there but
i can't say it away your entire yeah no
it's been it's been life's been good to
me
oh you know what i had i had hurt i had
heard about this yeah
hey do you steve green's like crush you
guys refer to this
we do all right yeah he's steve green
there's too many sleeves out there yeah
that's a lot of steep
and then uh yeah there's another friend
of ours that did the same thing but yeah
you were this big success story
cool yeah hey do you hear steve quit
comedy forever and now he's just into
money you know what i mean
he loves his money to steve look at you
you can do both you know what i mean
he's a money master that's right people
don't know
whatever happened with that what do you
mean
[Music]
[Music]
exactly
foreign